hello welcome to our
series which is a joint program of the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies law and divinity
I'm Matt Appleman I'm a first year law
student I'm Lexie Weintraub I'm a
third-year masters of environmental
management student at the School of
Forestry through this series we've
engaged with six leaders at the
intersection of these disciplines and
today we're very excited to continue
this discussion with Thomas Lovejoy
professor of environmental studies at
George Mason University in his early
career Professor Lovejoy established
biodiversity as a fundamental concept in
the ecological sciences and as a
fundamental priority for conservation
working in academia and the nonprofit
world professor Lovejoy has arguably
done more to advance the goal of
biodiversity preservation than anyone
else in a like position he has served as
the director of the World Wildlife Fund
u.s. program where he helped establish
tropical rainforest preservation as a
key priority worldwide he is also the
intellectual founder one of many
intellectual founders of innovative debt
for nature swaps which have opened over
a billion dollars of funds for
preservation in countries such as
Bolivia Costa Rica and Ecuador Professor
Lovejoy has served on numerous science
advisory positions with government NGO
and private sector boards and he has
planted the seeds of biodiversity
appreciation and advocacy and millions
of viewers of his critically acclaimed
public television program nature anyone
who recognizes the iconic Serengeti
acacia tree that marks the logo of that
TV show also recognizes the beauty and
complexity that you have helped us to
see in the natural world so we are
excited to be discussing your work today
thank you for joining us well it's great
to be here and I've just with a
respected nature the series that is the
fact that it is still running and so
successful after 33 years is actually a
very hopeful sign about public interest
absolutely there's a lot of demand for
what you all have been created
now you're the first of the scientists
that we've hosted and that we've had the
chance to talk to you on this program so
when I asked you briefly about your
dissertation work but in conjunction
with an ongoing conversation we've had
about place the importance of place in
this class I'm wondering if you can just
describe for us the rain forest in bail
in Brazil where you did your
dissertation work and what that meant to
you then and maybe what it means to you
now
in basic terms or in lofty terms so I
mean oh what a grand adventure for a
biologist a tropical rainforest
essentially as big as the 48 states with
only one highway right and only 3
million people and so rich in different
forms of a wife that there was always
something new
every day you went out it was pretty
exciting and I just looked at the number
of kinds of species of birds and how
they related the numbers and kinds of
species of trees and three different
kinds of forests and nobody have been
able to do that before mm-hmm and I can
just imagine it's the abundance of
species that you that you came across
well were you familiar with most of
those through your studies before you
came to see them yourself
or was a sort of an active process of
women so so it was so long ago that
there were no field guides so I
literally had to make my own field guide
up at the Peabody Museum and I got out
all the specimens all the species of
birds that hundreds that were known from
that part of the Amazon
I took Polaroid photographs and put them
in a notebook and turned it into a field
guide Wow and there were no English
names you know it was just Latin names
anyway it was fun you're a pioneer in a
way
in that effort well you know it's part
of having an adventure yeah that's so
exciting when you gave your blue planet
lecture prize or prize lecture you
talked briefly about the emergence of
land plants and modern flowering plants
as a key moment and global Earth
atmospheric balance because they drew
out so much co2 from the atmosphere and
you went on to say this was not just the
product of photosynthesis converting co2
into plant material it also involved the
creation of soil and the work of myriad
soil organisms it was a virtual
biodiversity symphony it's beautiful
language and it's a pleasure to hear it
and to read it what I hear from that
when I do read it is an attention to the
compositional art of the natural world
the air of your person is attuned to
that music in a way that you allow us to
hear it as well and so I'm wondering if
you can comment on what what do you
think the elements of that Symphony are
as as you perceive them or to put it
another way do you have an artistic
vision or an aesthetic that drives your
excitement in the natural world and that
maybe helps you to do the science that
you've done so so I chose that phrase to
sort of convey that this wasn't done you
know just by planting wall-to-wall
I don't know eucalyptus trees that it
was actually done by all kinds of
species all playing different kinds of
roles and that over you know tens of
millions of years it actually drew down
amazingly high levels of carbon dioxide
to pre-industrial levels as though there
was some sort of set point in the
Earth's
we don't know that that is in fact the
case but that's what happened right but
but when I when I look at nature I am
always astounded by just the sheer
variety of it things performing roles
that we are only just discovering that
can turn out to be useful or not and
when they don't turn out to be useful
it's just because we don't know enough
right now mm-hm
could well be useful and practical in
the future and you know for the last
10,000 years you know it's been a really
stable climate and so all these
relationships have gotten that much more
finely tuned and that's what we're busy
upsetting at the moment do you think
that there's there's a value to the
variety the amazing variety that you
talked about independent of use that is
also inherent to those things but which
we maybe haven't discovered like well
you know to me just the the variety of
life on Earth or the variety of so I was
saying to Mary Evelyn earlier the
variety of freshwater mollusks in the
Northeast United States is a wondrous
thing mm-hmm and then how they fit into
their actual communities and interact
and it's not just a bunch of objects
like a dead Natural History Museum
collection it's actually almost
organismic and the way they relate to
each other so it's exciting and it's
wondrous
and definitely agree so you have had a
long and varied career and I'm wonder if
we can go back to the early days you
finished here at Yale with your PhD in
1971 and coming out of graduate schools
rather than then staying on a
traditional research track it really
dove into working on how do we preserve
the biodiversity that that you had
talked so much about you know that had
become evident the level of lost during
the work on your dissertation at I'm
curious particularly here in a room full
of students who are about to graduate
and take those first steps you know you
really can't went off in a direction of
you know this new field of conservation
biology which you helped to create what
were those first steps like yeah as you
listen I mean the truth is I really made
it up as I went and I was basically I
was mostly interested in just having
scientific adventures and going to
really exotic places like the
mountaintops in East Africa with the
montane forests and then I got a chance
to go to the Amazon and then I was
looking for a job and heard that a
program project administrator job at the
World Wildlife on us employee number 13
and that sort of resonated with a lot of
things I had learned from my mentors
over time and I thought I'd go for two
years and then go back on the science
adventure track but I didn't because I
began to understand how incredibly
important it was how intrinsically
fascinating it was that you actually
needed to build a science to pursue
conservation which is why together with
Michael sula and some others you know we
created conservation biology and so I
ended up staying 14 years and the
challenge is you know just became
greater and more complex and more
fascinating and there was also the
opportunity to actually make a
difference and we did so you know when I
started Costa Rica had only three
national parks and the president Daniel
o to bear was about to either get rid of
one or cut it in half to do something
for a friend of his and really because
of the World Wildlife Fund and some key
people and Costa Rica including the head
of the national parks and the widow of
the famous Don Peppe who got rid of the
army in Costa Rica we were able to turn
that around so in the end Daniel Oda
bear became the first super green
president of Costa Rica and it just
built from that ever since and that's
you know Costa Rica's image they haven't
fallen into the mistake that's happened
to us of it becoming a partisan issue
and how evident was it as you started
down that path that you are making
progress that these changes would come
whether they what did it look like from
the from the beginning from your
perspective so I mean I said recently
you know when I started in in this game
conservation was something you did
because it was nice and because it was
right but today it's a central I mean we
really have to manage the planet as a
living planet it's a linked biological
and physical system and that means
paying a lot of attention to the big
global cycles of carbon and nitrogen and
the role of forests and how we abuse or
change how we use nitrogen fertilizers
and the list is long and you know the
ball but so in 1982 you joined the team
at nature and part of creating the show
and the PBS series which as you
mentioned is now in its 33rd season
which is incredible so the the nature
website says over the years Nature has
brought the beauty and wonder of the
natural world into American homes
I found that choice of emphasizing
beauty and wonder is interesting and I'm
wondering was that part of the initial
intention of that show and if so why so
so it started because I felt that World
Wildlife Fund could only get so far if
there wasn't more public awareness and
at that point there basically wasn't
much on television there were Marlin
Perkins reruns and an occasional massive
National Geographic special and that was
it so Scott McVeigh arranged for the two
of us to go see channel 13 in New York
and we showed the BBC film on the
Monteverde cloud forest where at the
beginning the trees are falling down and
you think oh they put the film in
backwards well actually they are running
it backwards and that's it's really hard
to put one of these back together again
and then the next hour is about the
wonders of cloud forest so we didn't
have any money we couldn't do what we
really originally wanted to do which was
actually sort of shed some light on the
various ways we're degrading the biology
of the planet and that's probably really
great because we fell into this pattern
which you just so nicely quoted from the
website which is to show basically the
beauty and wonder of nature and
and just very you know quietly so you
know this is in trouble right and that's
why it's still you know a series 33
years later if it had been the hard
punchy thing I was thinking about it
would have died after a year or two well
that just answered my follow-up question
was you know looking back after the 30
years of where we've come would you make
that would you make that same choice and
it sounds like yes you would I think so
yeah
people can only take so much bad news
and the actual beauty and wonder of it
is you know in many ways our best ally
in convincing people to do the right
thing many examples are stories of where
you've seen it be effective how you've
seen people be influenced by what
they've seen or experienced through that
show well I'm not thinking so much about
that show but I so there was a real
turning point in my life that we talked
about earlier today when I was with Tim
Wirth Al Gore and John Heinz and Ben
Bradley from the Washington Post and we
went to Brazil to see what could be done
to be helpful about deforestation and
then it turned out it was two weeks
after the assassination of the head of
the rubber tappers so the whole trip was
a very different kind of trip and I'd
never done anything like that before and
happily it was a really good bunch of
senators and Tim Wirth said to me don't
hold back and I would because I would
have I would have been intimidated but
the moment I knew that the trip was a
success was at the very end and we
didn't go into the forest until the last
afternoon and night of the trip and as
we went into the camp I saw two Raisa
Hans get fascinated with the term
like nest and that's when I knew the
trip was a success because that actually
is what it was all about and so nature
is in so many ways our best ally so
that's why I take people to my camp in
the Amazon all the time I want to
continue on that line up you've been so
successful with both the TV program and
your role at the World Wildlife Fund I'm
wondering I mean what can you attribute
that success to you've talked a little
bit about that I'm also wondering what
you see as the differences and the
conservation NGO world now as compared
to then can you still make the same sort
of impact that you have been able to
make with the World Wildlife Fund or
other factors is there too much
competition between these various groups
or other other factors that are in play
well when you're in the beginning of
something anything you can do is a plus
right and institutional considerations
become less important so literally in
our first year at the World Wildlife
Fund we gave a grant to the Nature
Conservancy to start the International
program mm-hmm you gave a grant to the
Natural Resources Defense Council to
start an international program and one
to the Environmental Defense Fund to
start their wildlife program which
Michael Biehn Wed brilliantly for many
years that's not the kind of behavior
that one would do today I don't think or
maybe under exceptional circumstances
but the fact that you know all those
organizations are much larger today it's
probably a good thing it's just that I
see the second law of thermodynamics in
the way institutions behave and the
bigger and more complicated they are the
more energy it takes to actually get
anything done it's always been the most
depressing law I'm gonna bring this
maybe to a more philosophical question
we've entertained some interesting
questions in this class about the rights
of nature and of non-human animals in
conjunction with visits from Wendy Anne
and Paul Waldo one of the questions for
example that arises is to invasive
species have a right to thrive in the
same way that a native species might as
an ecologist you represent a different
perspective on these sorts of
philosophical questions and I'm
wondering maybe your work on integrated
landscaping planning if I'm titling that
right addresses those rights by way of
thinking about minimum landscape size
and population genetics thinking about
what you need to support a species for
example with those considerations in
mind maybe some of those practical
frameworks do you think that Nature has
rights maybe from a gut personal level
as well and if so how do we honor those
does that question make sense well it's
an interesting question and in fact it's
in the constitution of Ecuador mmm-hmm
maybe and perfectly realized but it's in
the Constitution so
I think that since every species has a
four billion year pedigree that one
should really hesitate hesitate before
putting an end to that line of
evolutions and so I do think about it
that way
invasive species are an interesting
issue because it's mostly created by our
own behavior and it can really
complicate how one tries to sort of
manage the natural ecosystem so I'm not
one of those people who thinks the fact
that Porto Rico has a lot of introduced
species on it that it's actually you
know like it was 500 years ago it isn't
so within certain limits I think of it
just like you know weeding and garden
you want the natural part of it to
flourish it becomes much more
complicated with with climate change
where species are going to be moving
naturally and where I think that the
distinction if we let it go that far
between invasive species and species
tracking their required conditions will
really get blurred and then you get into
questions of assisted migration so my my
whole take on climate change is try and
keep it to a minimal level that's
actually where the consequences are
somewhat manageable
and the two-degree target the nations of
the world have agreed on is not
manageable it has no intrinsic merit it
was simply chosen because people thought
it was doable and you know biology Assad
you know the last time the planet was
two degrees warmer the oceans were four
to six meters higher I mean do you need
to know anything more I mean I don't
think you do right so I think that was
an okay response absolutely there there
are so many questions that that come up
with respect to climate change and and
management I think I want to speak about
the National Park Service management
plan that you mentioned or the rear
vision of it that you mentioned in a
lecture here in June 2013 you told us
how starker Leopold's management plan
was being revised and how the vignette
of primitive America meant to be
preserved by the national parks would
have to sort of transition to a moving
picture when we think about the
boundaries of protected areas and I'm
wondering in the context of our legal
frameworks surrounding property and land
if we need to change those and then
maybe what way do we need to be able to
shift property boundaries with shifting
plant ranges for protected land is that
the type of change that we might need in
law to approach the problems of climate
change or other other sorts of legal
issues that you think I should be raised
in this Coast if we were in Canada yeah
it would be a really serious problem
because all the parks in Canada each one
is created for
particular biological reason oh wow and
if it's no longer in the park it it's an
issue you know and we have some like
that Joshua Tree National Park is to
protect Joshua trees and they're
literally you know the range is moving
out of the park so I think actually what
we we need to do is think on an even
bigger scale and think about sort of
flipping the current model of nature
being embedded in a human dominated
matrix to the exact opposite where human
aspiration is is pursued within a
natural matrix and there's some parts of
the world where that's easier to do than
others it's not easy to do it in India
but one of the things that has really
struck me is how much connection gets
put back into a landscape if one
restores riparian vegetation and I
learned that because I was sent out to
by Bruce Babbitt to look at the
Northwest forest plan as it was being
developed and they were trying to decide
how wide the strip untouched for us
should be on either side of water
courses because salmon like logs and
streams and what I got out of it was not
just that it was the immense amount of
connection it puts back into the
landscape
and it's stuff you must ly want to do
anyway I mean prevent soil erosion they
get better water quality you know I've
been in Southern Illinois where
today most of the farmers do no-till but
because that's only relatively recent
there is so much topsoil it's in the
Illinois River that the government spent
16 million dollars to dredge it out and
sell it back to the farmers so I think a
lot of these things begin to be when
when the issue is really kinda one gets
from the status quo and people's own
vested interests to something that will
actually work better for everybody in
the end and it really requires a
different mindset do you think that
political jurisdictions or management
jurisdictions need to be more watershed
based if you're talking about riparian
habitats us and organizing principle not
only that I think we have to start
managing across those boundaries okay
and that's part of what was sort of
being implied in the revisiting Leopold
report okay that makes sense yeah so
it's evident from the way that you talk
about these systems that you have a real
sensitivity and awareness and and a real
connection to the way all of the pieces
fit together and you talk about this
idea of managing consciously managing
the globe consciously managing the earth
right that in in this way that we're a
part of it and were recognizing what
systems species organisms need at the
same time conservation scientists are
working internationally in places where
they're not from and are you know
working in to conserve areas where there
are people living who may have different
ways of knowing perceiving valuing
systems sort of how do we reconcile this
idea of you know in in some ways
conservationists conservation scientists
have you know a particular lens and a
particular and access to a particular
set of information
about the way we might manage landscapes
but how does that bump up against the
say the agency of indigenous people to
manage or make decisions and the lands
were in their base time I know you've
done a lot of work down in the Amazon
where there are a lot of contentious
issues around that if you have any
stories or examples or thoughts that so
so first of all I should say sort of
managing the planet as the linked
biological and physical system sounds
unbelievably arrogant but what it really
is about is managing ourselves and our
behavior so I learned pretty quickly
that the best way to advance
conservation even if you had the perfect
solution in your head is not to arrive
in somebody else's country and say oh
here's the answer it's go there and
really do a lot of listening and have a
lot of engagement and so what's so
interesting to me about the indigenous
people in the Brazilian Amazon is when I
was first working there the Brazilian
government didn't like anybody working
with indigenous people so conservation
was I've got see enough thing in itself
but to pair it with indigenous matters
would have would have been the exit door
so a lot has changed in Brazil and their
new constitution which i think is 1988
has really important provisions in there
for indigenous people and I mean
unbelievably almost all the indigenous
lands of the Brazilian Amazon
been demarcated and the the the rights
given to the indigenous people and its
27% of the Brazilian Amazon and it was
done with German money yes for a country
that used to really worry about its
sovereignty issues that was quite
amazing
and I think part of the trick there was
that the money went through the World
Bank the World Bank managed what was
called the g7 program for the Brazilian
rainforest and I can't resist telling
you once had dinner with president and
ruth cardoso to try and persuade brazil
to be the leader for sustainability
within the amazon pact which he got in
like 60 seconds but we were doing small
talk beforehand and he's asking me about
the g7 program and i said there well you
know this it's really remarkable thing
about the indigenous areas and then
fernando henrique and ruth started
talking about it at a level of detail I
couldn't possibly match and we ended up
we were talking about the then
contentious issue about the Yanomami
Indians up and where I'm aware the local
settlers didn't want the Yanomami to
have one big area they wanted to have a
bunch of little islands where they
happened to be at the moment and ruth
cardoso said well i'm in favor the
largest possible area it's good for the
forest it's good for the indians so one
of the really important things in brazil
was the effect of hosting the Earth
Summit that raised public consciousness
there to an unbelievable level so one of
our previous speakers in this course was
James Anaya
so Special Rapporteur on indigenous
rights and and you would argue that and
then the dunas group needs to have
agency over
those choices of what needs to happen
with the land so you know if that comes
into conflict with conservation goals
you know so be it what would you sort of
say to say to that or how would you
guide that you know long ago I figured
it would be the height of arrogance to
think of these indigenous areas as sort
of places where the indigenous people
lived according their culture frozen in
time and that's that's not going to be
the case and it shouldn't be the case I
think the issue is about rate of change
and the issue can also be about what
kinds of change and it's perfectly
reasonable to engage in conversations
around that and and there are NGOs that
do that I think very well and then they
start by giving the indigenous people
their GPS technology and they the
indigenous group sort of maps its own
land and for the first time how the even
better understanding than they did
before and so it's got to be an ongoing
exercise so if we can shift and talk a
bit about your own sort of cosmology I
know this this course is titled the
communion of subjects drawn from Thomas
Berry I know you've you've read and
whose work you've endorsed so I'd like
to read a passage of his from the new
story and have you comment a few would
so the impasse of the secular scientific
community committed to a developmental
universe is the commitment to the realm
of the physical to the exclusion of the
spiritual the Darwinian principle of
natural selection involves no psychic or
conscious purpose but is instead a
struggle for earthly survival that gives
to the world that's variety of form and
function because this story presents the
you
as a random sequence of physical and
biological interactions with no inherent
meaning the Society supported by this
vision has no adequate way of
identifying any spiritual or moral
values an integral story has not emerged
and no community can exist without a
unifying story he says the most notable
single development within science in
recent years however has been a growing
awareness of the integral physical
psychic dimension of reality as I wonder
what you think of this idea of the
universe as a psychic or conscious
entity so it's a really good question
and I don't know I can give you even a
halfway decent answer but to begin with
it's sentient and I am always struck by
how any child is immediately drawn to
any kind of living thing that has eyes
you just sort of something's gonna gotta
be going on inside there right so I
think we're actually through our own
evolution normally quite able to
appreciate that aspect of nature
it's just when we get really engaged in
our own social primate organizations and
tribes and whatever that we tend to
forget that we're connected to all of
that but I also I also always had a very
healthy respect for other people's
belief systems and I think it's
perfectly possible and reasonable and
maybe even desirable
two in the same individual have a value
system that thinks about the larger
questions of how we fit into the
universe and values at the same time as
being an actual scientific mind and you
know even even Darwin did that he was
conflicted he was deeply conflicted he
was both of those in the same individual
so would you would you agree that
there's that both are it sort of
suggests that hey there's this tension
between our religious worldview and the
scientific worldview that it's hard for
both the spiritual and this sort of
physical biological system that the
stories for each of those two really
cohere and resonate in a holistic way
would you agree that coming from you
know as coming from the scientific
community this view of the world as a
biological physical entity that lacks
sort of this spiritual or self reflexive
conscious sort of way of knowing itself
that that that that view is problematic
that that view maybe doesn't allow us to
make the changes culturally socially
that we would need to sort of correct
the path that were on so I'm not sure
that really is the case because if you
start with the premise that no organism
can exist without affecting other
organisms it's it's it's not whether you
do that or not it's it's how you do it
in what way in what ways and that by
Neph it definition I think has to
include a value system
so I think it's it's more than
appropriate if not essential we all try
and think in both those ways I love that
and I love the focus on sentience that
you were discussing earlier also like
thinking of the scientific community as
an essential part of the sort of global
human sentience and awareness of our
environment and yeah and in the process
of discovery and the process of
discovery as individual scientists and
as as a species and so I want to come
back to science a little bit and a sense
of discovery surrounding that I'm gonna
read a section of your abstract from the
2011 biological conservation article
that you wrote with William Lawrence and
many others and then I'm gonna ask a
question and ok promise I'll ask the
question in general populations and
communities of species and fragments are
hyper dynamic relative to nearby intact
forests some edge and fragment isolation
effects have declined with a partial
recovery of secondary forest around
fragments but other changes such as
altered patterns of tree recruitment are
ongoing fragments are highly sensitive
to external vicissitudes and even small
changes in local land management
practices may drive fragmented
ecosystems in markedly different
directions these effects are likely to
interact synergistically with other
anthropogenic effects such as logging
hunting and especially fire creating an
even greater peril for the Amazonian
biota peril notwithstanding that's an
exciting piece of text in my opinion I
was excited when I was reading it it has
a decade of view of the landscape at
least decadal and it encompasses many
variations and possible contingencies
and wondering if that dynamism that I
see in the text itself and in the
landscape that's described
in the text I'm wondering if that is a
key component of your process and your
reason for doing science or if it's just
a way of catching people's attention and
if you'll exclude excuse me excuse the
lofty language can we treat in some ways
the abstract as a poem which is
transformative both for the reader of it
but also for the doer of it the person
who writes the abstract and who did the
science and who made the discovery is
that one of your reasons for doing
science because it's transformative when
you learn about the world around you or
is there another reason so why do I do
science I do I do science because it's
fascinating but I do particular kinds of
science because I think it can help us
make better decisions about how we
relate to the world and what is
particularly interesting given that
choice of what you just read is I
thought a lot about why habitat
fragmentation wasn't even considered an
issue when I was in graduate school
and I think it's I think it's because
you don't see the changes right away you
have to be doing science like that paper
is referring to to actually see what is
actually considerable change but you
don't you don't just go out in the
landscape and see it happening and it's
interesting to me I think if you go back
and look at the work of ruth patrick who
figured out that the numbers and cons of
species in a river give you a readout on
its natural conditions plus the stresses
in the human landscape that that then
led to a whole series of papers iran
species diversity and
you know my thesis was one of us but you
know MacArthur was really interested in
that question and in Wilson and then
they did the theory of Island
biogeography and all of a sudden the
question was there are isolated bits of
forest in a human dominated landscape
like Islands and we'll species number be
deeply affected by different things and
then people started studying it and yeah
it is amazingly dynamic and it is it is
a major way we are changing the biology
of the planet and so you know I started
out to do the forest fragments project
as a 20-year project to answer a simple
question should it be big protected area
or a bunch of small ones and I have no
ideas about rates of change and we're
now in year 36 and it's still changing
and it's going to be institutionalized
so people can look at it a hundred years
from now or whatever because we really
need to understand these things if we're
to manage the place in any reasonable
way mm-hmm I'm just so impressed by the
vision of being able to incorporate
natural history or transition natural
history into the accepted science of
biological conservation that the group
of individuals including you were able
to do at that time was that something
that you intentionally set out to do to
sort of establish Natural History as a
legitimate science in conjunction with
biology or in the form of biological
conservation so you have to understand
that the person who really transformed
natural history into a science was G
Yvonne Hutchinson who was my thesis
advisor yeah and he cared about
conservation as did many others so it
was
it was just a logical thing for me when
I got to the World Wildlife Fund to
start thinking of what are the science
questions we have to address we're going
to do this in a successful way mm-hmm
and then one thing leads to another well
we're all indebted to you for that and I
think I'm gonna quote you again this
time from your blue planet lecture
species are changing where they occur
I'll paraphrase you the Edith's
Checkerspot butterfly one of the two
most studied species butterfly species
in North America has clearly been moving
northward and upward you talked about
Joshua trees moving out of Joshua Tree
National Park and you also talked in
that lecture about ponderosa pines
moving up elevation and the sense that I
come away with when reading that text is
that this is a great migration that
we're experiencing right now it's not a
migration in any one particular
direction but it's an epoch that
somebody needs to tell us about and you
are one of the few people that have been
able to reach the multitudes and part
through your television program but also
by working with policy leaders at the
top of governments all across the earth
and so I'm wondering as you continue to
tell that epic how are you making sure
that others take up that scroll or maybe
maybe what what is your vision if you
could write the next chapter in in that
news story if we want to use the
language of Thomas berry what would the
storyline be is so so here's my ideal
next chapter okay all right and maybe a
whole bunch of chapters it's it's when
we all scientists and non-scientists and
value leaders alike
get beyond thinking about calling the
current time on earth the Anthropocene
because of the human impact on it and
and actually earned the right to call it
the Anthropocene because we have gotten
control of our own behavior and are
bringing this back into some kind of
equilibrium that's fascinating
we've had other discussions about the
Anthropocene in this class but I loved
that vision of where we are now and
we're where we should be thank you so
much for joining us it's been a great
it's been a pleasure thank you